Boy, as views go, that one's not bad. Good morning, Hank. It's Friday.
And I'm in Bellingham, Washington at a literature conference
So Hank, over the weekend, there's going to be a Question Tuesday video not on Tuesday.
Nerdfighters pleased to be leaving your questions and comments.
But today Hank,
I want to ask you a question.
I was walking backwards.
Hank, we've been making videos back and forth for more than three years
and in all that time we have never once discussed Red Green.
And I'm starting to wonder
whether maybe that's because
you are guilty of a terrible crime.
Now, Hank, the preface to this story is that when I was a kid,
I had a best friend,
Nintendo Entertainment System.
Nintendo and I went to everywhere together,
which is to say that I never left the house.
Hank, there was nothing in life that made me happier
than when I would press that NES power button
and hear those fateful words
[Nintendo]: "BLADES OF STEEL"
Still sends a shiver down my spine.
And of course, we also had a dog,
a miniature dachshund named Red Green,
who hated me.
By the way, Hank, if you're wondering
I'm on my way to a bookstore to try to secretly sign some of my books.
Now Hank, as you probably remember,
the original Nintendo Entertainment System had a plastic flap
which you opened and then removed a game cartridge or put one in.
And sometimes, at the end of a long day of playing
Zelda and Mario and Double Dribble and Blades Of Steel,
I would remove that last game cartridge
and because I was not as good a friend to Nintendo
as Nintendo was to me,
I would leave that plastic flap open.
Now Hank,
There can be no question, that in his life, Red Green did many terrible things.
He enjoyed biting children.
He would pee on my bedroom carpet
while staring me in the eyes.
Oh look I'm a Staff Pick!
But Hank, in our family, Red Green is most famous for what I discovered one summer morning,
when I woke up,
dragged myself to the living room
and went to go play Nintendo.
You see, Hank,
Red Green
had pooped
in my best friend,
the Nintendo.
I don't mean he pooped ON the Nintendo.
I mean, he pooped IN the Nintendo.
I had left the plastic flap open overnight,
and when I went to put Blades Of Steel in the machine,
I discovered red poop,
Well the poop wasn't actually red, it was brown,
but it was from Red.
Now Hank, the list of suspects for the crime is really limited to our nuclear family
and Red himself
because it happened overnight and the doors were locked.
Now, I know I didn't do it
because I loved that Nintendo more than I loved my own...
I'll just say it,
brother.
Mom or Dad is certainly a possibility
but I think they like the Nintendo,
it minimized the amount of time I was annoying them.
Plus it's just hard to imagine either of our parents
picking up dog poop
and inserting it into a Nintendo.
Inexplicable gazeboooo.
So, far as I can tell, this leaves two possibilities:
One:
you put the poop in the Nintendo,
or two:
in the middle of the night, Red Green awoke in a fit of violent jealousy,
backed up to the Nintendo,
placing his bum against its opening,
and proceeded to
projectile poop into the Nintendo.
Unfortunately Hank,
because I know just how nefarious a dog Red Green was,
I cannot discount that possibility.
This means if we were playing Clue,
I would know the murder weapon and the location,
--it was Red Green's poop
in the Nintendo--
but, even after all these years, I still do not know the murderer.
Hank,
I think enough time has passed for you to answer the question honestly.
Did you put Red Green's poop in the Nintendo?
Or was Red Green some kind of pooping genius?
Hank, I expect your answer on Monday.